Oh welcome back and we're back and we're
back I'm hacked from the nebulous know
where space is the last episode ended
yeah welcome back to dank ass Stubbs
it's a dank ass Wednesday afternoon on a
dank ass part of town dang guess summer
day it's like a every the time tank is
actually kind of Herod we gotta we gotta
read we're gonna make our own book your
gym read as a kid out of the dark dark
dark dark room oh [ __ ] that means yeah
that really [ __ ] up there was so dark
and skins [ __ ] on me we need to make our
own version of the day dang dang dang
room in the dank dank dank dank room in
a dank dank dank dank house this is a
dang dang dang dang shelf this is
horribly moist drippy house the water
log down exactly it's like a house in a
part of town that's been under a little
just underhill repairs after a flood
after a flood of civil kind not like a
like a truly disastrous flood but enough
that like everything kind of still water
logged you ever see that that photo of
that dude like standing in his basement
and he's in water that's up to his waist
he's just got this sad look on his face
with his arms crossed you posted that
photo on Facebook with the caption my
baseman had gotten no business looking
like this no bit of basement lock your
[ __ ] up yeah so welcome back to jank ass
dubs were you know we're tooling around
man were this is the part where we break
the fourth wall yeah we're tweaking man
we're tweaking out doing drugs not so
much we're not doing drugs Rangers I've
never drugged in my life uh except for
steroids yeah shut up no get it thank
you I'm natty natty ice seously oh by
the way dança Stubbs is brought to you
by Frankie yes upswing yes robes if
anything is going to change in the show
it is not gonna be that yeah slices
marinades for your beef in your poultry
beefy poultry we have pork if you swing
that fork yeah if you're if you aren't
keeping kosher my name is Aaron my name
is Jerry I'm sorry we have a hooker in
here oh uh no we don't know who cop we
have a hookah um yeah this is new yeah
this is new wasn't that new this is like
round three Lego like I've only ever had
like that done how do you refer what's
what's the lingo do you do a jugar do
you just like enjoy one I have no idea
cuz it's not a drugs it's just kind of
an experiment gotten nicotine so in a
sense it are you getting me a high I
didn't mean to okay nicoderm CQ you can
quit if you are quitter if you have the
quitting gene is there I mean today I
know there's like a genetic component to
addiction buzzer genetic component to
look quitting specifically I don't think
so if they if they isolate the [ __ ]
gene so it's like somebody very
non-committal and just like kind of
gives up on things like that's they have
that gene yeah you got the [ __ ] gene
and you know the eggs it can be managed
yeah but it's not something you can do
about it you're always gonna live with a
little bit of [ __ ] it that's your that's
your mr. Bravo Duke living in the
basement you can only ever feed him you
know scraps he's never gonna go away
yeah feed him worms from the garden see
ya we're tweaking out right now we're
you know beta testing for dank ass
Stubbs is gone you know pretty well then
um you know we're working out some of
the kinks some of the bugs taking in
some valuable feedback some of the
saying awesome keep doing this some of
them saying this is boring yeah so we're
we're gonna the next couple episodes it
seems like we're probably going to be
experimenting with some things no maybe
introducing some new stuff as ideas come
along because hey you know I mean these
are these are off the cuffs man yeah
these are these are these are jazz solos
man so I mean it might be cool at some
point to get to a point where we have
like at least vague segments I don't
know what they would be what are you
watching this week is this the segment
it could be what are you watching us we
just watching things we um watch monster
it's past week God well I'm lying I've
watched a lot of stuff in the past few
weeks that I feel like talking about
I've been watching a lot of things the
past few weeks but in the past week or
so I've been
been busy I was I was I had to arrange
my life to get up to palmdale get to
finish a shoot and then come back from
that was an Ephraim and music with it it
was not it was not an a from a music
video it was a it was a a tiny budget
film okay that that maybe if the thing
actually gets finished and released to
the world I feel like I will have a
funny story to tell um go see that thing
people dig up later on yeah like that
like Tom Hanks is um dungeons and
dragons movie new dungeons reinsman yeah
back in the 80s during the whole satanic
panic period where people were certain
that doing dungeons dragons would lead
you the Satan I'm so I mean the Tommy
Titanic panic is like a legitimate term
of some kind yeah um Tom Hanks was as a
lad in a movie about some teenagers that
got sucked into the occult via a week
stand-in for Dungeons and Dragons i
think was called mazes and monsters or
something like that I never saw such a
film but but it did happen and
apparently they're like now the Tom
Hanks's is an a-list actor they've
reissued that movie a few times in like
bargain bin DVDs and the cover shows Tom
Hanks as Robert Langdon from The Da
Vinci Code movies light in front of like
a gothic castle with like a flying
gargoyle in the background so it looks
like a totally different movie ok I I
know this [ __ ] what is it called I don't
I can't remember thinking just Google
Tom Hanks Dungeons and Dragons Satan
you're either going to get something
about the movie or a very weird
conspiracy theory about Tom Hanks hey I
mean both would probably be amusing at
this or at least and um that's
interesting so wait such was the Reagan
years man it was a one time to be alive
hey ray sorry I was just watching a wet
hot American summer first day of came
first day at camp how was that is funny
as [ __ ] I mean like yeah
I I quite enjoy the movie and I quite
enjoyed that kind of we were talking
about this earlier today I quite enjoy
that Brent of like really absurd comedy
so it's you know that appeals to me and
usually when I'm writing copy that's the
kind of thing I like to write alright
its natural end up writing so like
there's so much absurdity and there's so
many strange little jokes and the sides
and things um so I had a blast I mean it
was you know it was everything it's kind
of you know scary to get excited about
anything now them you know I've seen all
eight episodes the show and I had a
blasty blast you know they did it they
managed to to stick the landing and I
think they approach to the right way
because they brought everybody back and
they have a lot of fun with the fact
that these eight episodes take place
over one day for the most part and
everyone is younger but they're all 15
years older oh and there's I think
there's even a joke at some point
somebody says you know like man by the
end of camp we're gonna feel 15 years
younger because you know I I could stand
to see the movie again cuz it's been a
while yeah I mean you know it's it's
it's fun you know it's it's wacky and
it's I don't know it does its thing it
has the quality that i think is starting
to be more appreciated now because like
it came out and I got really poor
reviews and I have a movie or the or the
show oh no the movie the show i think is
received better because the movies you
know respect and love for that movie has
grown much over the past over the years
and and I ever had a couple articles
that sort of touched on that is like
maybe wet hot American summer was just
made at the wrong time because that was
2001 it came out and yeah now we're
seeing more of these comedy pieces that
are you know sort of referential to a
different time in place it's like it's
the summer coming of age you know teen
comedy but just remixed and and totally
absurd and now we also have things like
the spoils of Babylon which is you know
a very distinct call back to a kind of
you know TV movie and so
just these kinds of things are more the
cultural sphere so that they're less out
of left field yeah I think that could be
a thing because it's like if you're if
you're parroting something that's very
specific like you know the the
coming-of-age teen sex comedy set at a
summer camp that's such a specific thing
and spoils of Babylon even more so it's
like you know the 70s potboiler yeah
mini series of you know about like kind
of this overwrought family drama
spanning generations it's like that's
those are such specific things to
lampoon yeah so you have to have a
culture like you know like we have in a
post Internet age or where people are
more appreciative of things that
specific yeah people people are more
interested in things that are that that
particular yeah one you know nostalgia
is such a big thing and everything i'm
having suppose babylons done what
because i think that's a cool thing
because it's still funny and it can also
sort of open up a door because you know
i mean i got imagine maybe half the
people or a certain percentage lisa the
people who have seen spoils of babylon
specifically you know at least weren't
around for what it's a reference to yeah
you know or or haven't seen a million of
those so it's like you know i watched
some of those episodes with my folks and
it's like they were gonna kick out of it
because they'd seen all those movies and
i was getting a kick out of it because
they'd shown me some grass so it's like
you know i didn't live through them you
know like they did and so we had some
different perspectives we were still
able to enjoy it for what was it was
fine i remember seeing wet hot american
summer um the movie and it's it's where
i could send to see it again because
it's like you know it was one of those
things where you know you watch it just
at home and you don't really get
absorbed into it so i could stand to
watch that movie again but i remember my
closest point of reference tool was
oddly enough dazed and confused which
was kind of a totally different sort of
i gotta see it I gotta say home early
Linklater yeah cuz I do love the link I
feel like Jason confused is I mean
there's early Linklater and stuff like
dazed and confused and there
Linklater and the stuff like slacker
yeah and those are very different
animals yeah that get some early link
and I do I mean I appreciate when
someone can really go off on a tangent
of just absolutely absurd humor yeah and
and really commit to it and really roll
with it because I mean this was a
Babylon for instance like there's a
whole they just roll with one character
being a mannequin yeah this is cat it's
just kind of it that's the thing that we
were talking again you guys weren't
there we were talking about this earlier
cuz we exist outside of these our chunks
I know right um it's like an animated
shows now more and more you know we're
embracing that words like you have
things like you were talking about uncle
grandpa yeah I've only sampled bits of
uncle grandpa and most of I think the
biggest chunk of my exposure to uncle
grandpa came from the the Steven
universe crossover episode they did
which was which was just this really
just front-loaded joke gasm that episode
okay um it's just so I mean I was been
taking to the Steven universe by my girl
friend introduced me to the show and I
just binge that entire series and it's
it's a good [ __ ] show no but it gave
me an intro to Uncle grandpa beyond just
the pilot short that I remember seeing
way back when an uncle's course intro to
uncle yeah exactly uncle grandpa
one-inch uncle grandpa 91a the remedial
course yeah if you if you didn't get
enough uncle grandpa in high school
uncle grandpa's a show where I don't
know how much anyone could tolerate like
big chunks of it cuz I don't know what
the show is like as a whole but in the
little distinct chunk chunks I've gotten
of it I have to respect anything that is
just that much of falling down the
dante's inferno hole 22 visual gag hell
yeah but in a good way I mean that in
the best way well I'll go grab I was
just like oh
aggressively in your face and artistic
and wacky but in a very fun and very
kind of sweet and endearing way yeah and
I haven't seen that much of it but from
the it really does feel like uncle
grandpa feels like being a kid and
interacting with your wacky uncle yeah
works like this is this is the guy who
is so fun and so chaotic and so bizarre
and everything about it was just kind of
crazy and exciting and then years later
as an adult you think oh he was an
alcoholic wasn't he except uncle grandpa
s wages that that ugly feeling that ugly
posthawk sensation we're just like no
means the whimsy it maintains the whimsy
like there are times when Uncle grandpa
will enter will be in a room talking to
somebody and then a second uncle grandpa
will just show up and continue uncle
grandpa's dialogue and then for like
another few shots there are two uncles
grandpa just cuz just [ __ ] cuz see I
love when it comes to huber like that
when it comes to absurd humor i love
just cuz and i'm not super deep into
adventure time to wear like it's the
point in adventure time i'm at it like
it's starting to get you know like oh
like here are some actual poignant
things but that's from the earliest you
know viewings i've had is what i loved
about adventure i was like there's a lot
of stuff that happens just because
because somebody in the animation river
and the in the writers room was like
well you know they're in this place why
don't we just put that in the background
as i just kind of makes sense be sure
like and wet hot american summer has you
know not granted it's live action so you
can't do certain things but there's
something about having weird things
happen and just all the characters just
continue as though that's how the
universe works and it's not weird to
them so it's it's [ __ ] like I don't
know this that humor really tickles me
and there's so much of that and they you
know they jump back and forth between
there there's lots of visual gags and
there are lots of outright silly absurd
gags like there's this whole chase scene
that just involves like impossible
physics like guys trying to hide from
crisp ken marino is trying to hide from
Chris Maloney and like he's very clearly
on
bedsheets and Chris Maloney's looking
around like really he's so Chris Mullin
is so good in this shut up he's looking
right and that he pulls the bed sheets
out and they do some kind of man cut
where he's look he's just gone he crawls
out from over a bunk bed and like
they're you know it's yes certain things
like that there are times when like
it'll totally shift like there was a
subplot with Jenny krofl oh and uh Jason
Schwartzman who's not in the movie but
he's on the show and it just became
imagine the what I can't even remember
the last or most reason thing I saw what
you need garofalo in it yeah I know it's
and and you know it was nice to see her
again all the way she seems like she's
just work done yeah I always makes me
sad but like there's a subplot with her
and Jason Schwartzman which is so funny
because it just becomes a cop show like
not not with all the tribes but it's
just like enough it's like it's shot
that way all of a sudden huh and they're
like saying the things those two kinds
of characters would say Michael Cera
shows up for some very funny lawyer is
he a kitty cat man or no a kitty cat man
yeah you don't remember the Tim and Eric
bit where michael cera is the kitty cat
man no I haven't seen much to her I feel
like I now is the time where I would
start to appreciate it because like I'd
seen Tim and Eric on cartoon network
like or on adult swim the late at night
and I was always kind of creeped out
advise him Eric yeah Tim America is
something that you do kind of have to
gird your loins for because it does get
aggressively I mean I didn't grow up
like this but I had one guy once tell me
it's like what i love about tim and eric
is when i was a little kid um when I was
a little kid my family was really like
you know really strapped for money was
really poor and so most of the TV I
watched as a kid was public access TV
which is all really unprofessional and
slapdash and oftentimes really creepy
and really weird and you know just
absolute maniacs get attracted to doing
public access TV and so because of that
watching Tim and Eric is hilarious to me
because it's commenting and kind of
parodying just how
cert and creepy and bizarre public
access TV can be those like public
access but if it was quite as weird as
you remembered it yeah seems like but ya
know I don't know I just it tickled me
to have that bag and it tickled me that
they that they seem to nail it like you
know I mean that's that's the kind of
humor you can do where you could jam
pack jokes and there are so many
different characters there's so many
subplots but I'm hesitant cuz I don't
want to give away jokes because there's
so many things that are funny to me but
what hot summer in America and
translates well into a show cuz they get
a lot of mileage out of that alone
because it's like over once you get a
couple episodes and you start to it
starts to catch up with you you're like
wait a minute so many things have
happened it's only been like an hour
like you know and then they start to you
know everything is very self-conscious
in just the right way where they start
having fun with the fact that it seems
like so much time is left as so many
huge things have happened and it's only
been like you know four or five hours
you know by the time certain [ __ ] starts
to hit the fan so to speak so that's
that's one of the things I've been and
that's something that's hilarious to me
because it's like the fact that is going
to sustain this taking over the course
of a summer by by having every season be
a whole day yeah I mean if they are I
hope I would I would hope I just in the
middle of season two they flash forward
five years yes just the rest of the the
rest of the series just continues from
there the thing is like I saw that and I
also I saw that movie for the first time
not super recently but more recently and
so I feel like I saw it at a better time
to see it whereas like it fits more and
so you know it's like seeing this I was
like oh good they did it and now it's
like I would love more but I also kind
of would be free uh-huh you know it's
like I almost feel like taking a long
time off is the way to make this keep
working boom the coals by boy um and I
also started on you guys will meet
Charlie one day
but i'll go on Charlie's recommendation
i begin to Marc Maron lately oh yeah I
listened to first episode of his podcast
site I listen to this podcast of where
he asked what is the [ __ ] what is the
[ __ ] what is the [ __ ] and why why is the
[ __ ] I listened to his Obama episode
which is very interesting really yeah is
that Obama and now I'm you know I've
worked my way around but I also started
watching his show two seasons are on the
first two seasons are on the netflix
what's the Obama episode of his TV show
like da involved oh well that I don't
think Obama came on the show that's lame
but he just do the audio but he did come
to his garage in Highland Park yeah so
well that's cool Obama that's cool the
Obama you know POTUS of the Potters
we're all into those acronyms now POTUS
and scotus and FLOTUS now scotus is
terrible because I all I can think of a
scrotum skoda sounds like a disease yeah
I got scotus I have to apply this cream
where's like a like a colonial-era
disease specifically something that you
would only contract on the Oregon Trail
yeah exactly now uh y'all follows
contracted the SCOTUS oh it's breathing
his last now you best come say your
goodbyes it's one of those diseases that
like hasn't been a problem since then
and occasionally it'll pop up in the
modern times and it's like you just take
these antibiotics and you'll be fine
yeah but like back back in the Oregon
Trail times the [ __ ] of your whole
colony scotus miss Otis scotus I that's
my new [ __ ] though and now it's so cool
stuff I try to I tried to make fridge
catch on and we try to make MIT happen I
still want myth to have I feel like we
just didn't I think we got to be honest
and admit that we neither of us really
had the will to really make this new
slaying work yeah yeah well because I
you know deep new slang is a song that
will change your life if Natalie Portman
catches you in a hospital waiting room
and forces you to listen to it is that
from garden stay exactly there I've been
really big I guess this is just like the
one have you been ingesting with your
eyes and ears this segment of the show
yeah this whole episode is it yo check
this out segment exactly I've been
getting really big into spoon lately
spoons bands in austin texas um i think
people know whose food yes it was
[ __ ] great i picked up like for their
albums and and you know spoon btdubs
erica's in the booth yeah oh [ __ ] you
guys are talking on the thing yeah oh
[ __ ] haha totally didn't realize they're
just like talking to each other I didn't
realize that you were actually oh you
really didn't realize no I didn't oh I'm
sorry no it's ok but i'm making chili
what's erica's making mad chill yes
that's why I'm apologizing it there's
background sounds what eat a bowl of
chili while you now that I know ok thank
you now Erica will make quiet chili nah
eat a bowl a'chili while you listen yeah
um but ya know like I this is now the
chili is the second screen and this is
the second screen experience screen
being a bowl a'chili I'd love that joke
on Bojack horseman oh cool i love stupid
[ __ ] like dude wish it like i love dumb
bull [ __ ] like this but you know like i
was playing i think i turn my camera on
it was just on my playlist cuz i heard
that song somewhere i was applying and i
was driving Charlie home and like funky
funky track with some bee gees esque you
Noakes one and you know spoon traverse
it like I was listening to a needle drop
review of their most recent album which
has to the fanta know to the fanta know
banan thony mango here slam thony dumped
a no and he you know he did a relatively
favorable review of their recent their
most recent out but he sorta described
them as one of those bands that's like
like a reliable car it's like you know
that it's not necessarily like super out
there but there is a lot of passion and
there is a lot of personality and you
know just real creativity like that it
seems like they're always good at
throwing something interesting in it's
like okay here
sort of a fuzzy grow I wasn't expecting
this here and like you know especially
like kill the moonlight you know there's
some some out their choices that are
really cool there's one song that's
driven by a beatbox huh just him just
got cut and like they turn that into a
song oh there's another song that that
builds on these different drum patterns
that like one has a flange on it and so
it becomes an instrument instrument even
that's the drum there's lots of cool
stuff going on but I'm getting back to
the original point of why I brought up
spoon in this conversation oh I'm on the
edge of my seat it tickled me so because
there is a song I think it's outlier um
on they want my soul which is their most
recent record where he says something
along the lines of I remember when you
walked out of garden state cuz you had
taste you had taste you had no time to
waste huh like oh [ __ ] britt daniel
calling out Garden State yeah that movie
I ain't seen Garden State I gotta see a
lot more movies you know I feel weird
cuz like you know this is I feel like
network I feel like if you're gonna go
into watching Gardens they do it to
participate in the conversation to join
the watering hole yeah enjoy the water
cooler many years too late and then make
make your judgment as to whether or not
you like it or not cuz I feel like um I
mean it's great i'm gonna like her and
stay a lot and I don't know why I would
be afraid but i am the Garcia is one of
those movies works like I liked it when
I was 14 but yeah I'm so about that as I
think I like to when I was 14 i think i
was 14 when I saw it I liked it all
right but I think as time has gone on
the movie probably hasn't you know I
feel as you I don't think it's aged well
and I think it's like I think the people
i don't know how to put it it's like to
the people that would be interested in
seeing a movie like garden state garden
state is not saying anything new to them
whereas the people
for whom garden state would say
something new to them they wouldn't be
interested in gardens say to begin with
interest I will have to see this film
yeah it's on the top of my list I'm not
dropping everything I'm just kidding hey
I must watch gardens day right now stop
the episode no i gotta i gotta finish
these into maritime I've really come to
like him like his show anyway I gotta
watch season two a true detective even
though it sucks but I want to be I want
to be part of the conversation about why
it sucks and how it sucks is it done
yeah it's over and if it still suck yeah
apparently it sucked well that's a
bummer I know it's real bummer and I
think I think maybe what we're what we
got to kind of wake up to is maybe that
the first season of True detective was
not great but it just kind of teased at
not sucking for long enough that you
know we got some gems out of it
interesting I that's another one I got I
got I got a jump on I mean the
everything I first heard about it's
weird everything I've heard about the
new season of true objective is like all
the performances are great this episode
is kind of boring I don't watch the next
one though and this isn't very good i'm
just gonna keep watching it yeah like
and and that's sort of what settled into
it's just everyone i know who was was
watching the show going like man this is
a letdown that i'm going to continue
devoting time to yeah i think that's
just say cuz it's like the first season
of True detective was slow burn so it's
like the second season of the first
season Trudeau Jake it was like oh this
is a slow burn how's this gonna pan out
and then it only kind of half panned out
interesting and then the second season
is like everyone seems to have been like
oh this isn't really great but I'm gonna
see I'm gonna wait for this to get good
and that's like oh the season's over and
it didn't get good yeah most of the
complaints I heard at least early on
more people going I've what is this
building towards we're discussing like
highway planning yeah
I don't know and then I saw like five
minutes of an episode where Elizabeth
Banks was like doing one of those knife
practice things and getting ready for
crazy orgy party up so all I know about
the first season true detective is there
was something involving in chrome asked
and a sex party and Colin Farrell like
saying dialogue like same dialogue to
some teachers kid after I think it was a
teacher like somebody screwed over Colin
Farrell's kid at school so he went to
the house of whoever was whether it was
like another parent or teacher or
whatever beats up the parent and then
the kid watches it and then says
something like trying to intimidate
people but it sounds like a teenager
wrote this and thought it sounded bad
ass on paper it was one of those you can
write this [ __ ] but you can't act it
dude that's a bummer yeah poor Trudy
poor Trudy poor Nick pizzeria yeah who's
Nick pizzeria Nick it's a lot of the
writer showrunner of true detective both
seasons yeah um I wish I could remember
the specific name to to say his name but
the director of all eight seasons of all
eight episodes of last season was Cary
Fukunaga exactly yeah yeah um and
apparently there's like a character
whose like a shitty director in season
two true detective and people are like
okay Nick pizza lotto is clearly trying
to vent steam about some frustrations he
had with cary fukunaga which is kind of
[ __ ] cuz cary fukunaga is direction
is what made the first season yeah so I
don't know it's like what's all I mean
we've all really enjoyed like a lot of
great Oh tourist TV in the past few
years yeah but then stuff like this kind
of comes back and bites you in the ass
and I don't know it's like I yeah I'm
the thing about like thinking of things
in auteur way or or not it's like you
know I get it yes you know everyone in a
everyone you know film is a very
collaborative medium but it's like if I
have to
choose between a movie where it's
designed by one guy with a lot of
artistic intent or a bunch of guys
sitting around a boardroom and you know
doing kind of like designed by committee
for the sake of you know marketing
reasons I don't I would go I would
rather go with the one guy running the
ship as long as he's not an [ __ ] yeah
I think that's the problem it's like
we're we think of like we we accept
movies being done in like we accept with
these TV shows or anything like filmic
medium being kind of run in one or two
directions where it's like all handled
by the studio or it's all handled by a
no tourist director and I feel like
maybe that's why things are why there
are so many cool things going on in
animation right now because what I see
in a lot of animated shows nowadays is
there's a collaborative auteur ISM in a
sense like beau jack is a really great
show where it's like you know you have
you know Raphael bah blocksberg as as
the showrunner on the writing side then
you have Lisa Hanawalt who's running the
design and animation side of things and
then you have all these strong creative
voices but their collaborative and
they're not unison you know they're not
they're not all stuck in one person you
know it's like it's not a matter of you
know it's not a matter of Lisa Hanawalt
really wants to make design the show so
that it works to Rafael's you know
vision it's no you know the people
working in animation and design and the
people working and writing a story
they're all they're all working together
and coming to something that's kind of
greater than themselves and that's the
work and that's the piece mm-hmm um what
and that seems to be as sort of I don't
know the ins and outs with that seems
like a fortunate aspect of being with
Netflix is like seems like Netflix
acquires stuff and doesn't make heap
tons of demands about like we're gonna
come in and make this a Netflix this
just seems like they they find what they
think will work
and then order it yeah then that I mean
that was also say HBO's model but I
guess you know things haven't panned out
great in the long run with true
detective where it had you know this one
guy at the helm yeah where their flashes
are brilliant to them things that just
didn't work in season two apparently I
don't know I mean I I would like to cuz
I give me you chart the the way in which
the way in which like American movies
have kind of gone it feels like there's
this battle between these two opposing
forces where it's director of control
versus studio control and how those
things have panned out words like you
know the 30s and 40s were all very
studio control e to a big extent you
know it was you know the the studio and
the producers had these dictates in
these demands as to what the movie was
like and what the studio's Yelp products
were all like and then you had you know
moving into yet transitions and then you
had into the 60s and 70s were you know
the new Hollywood Oh tourist model was
in effect and you know it's like oh this
is the new scorsese movie then you know
this is all this is Hitchcock and this
is de palmen you know it's like and you
know Hitchcock becomes a character that
everyone recognizes as being you know
this artsy director guy or this not
artsy but you know this this prominent
you you know very Napoleonic director
guy but then afterwards the story comes
out it's like oh yeah that was to
everyone else's expense working on any
project that Hitchcock was on it's like
for whatever brilliance a lot of people
got shafted and yeah and you know a lot
of people were abused abused yeah for
not you know falling in line with the
program you know but that's like I would
like to see I mean I would like to see
um i would like to see us go into a mode
of you know I guess collaborative ought
tourism where people are like oh man
it's this writer and this director and
this actor and together
they're going to basically do like a
supergroup yeah yeah yeah I mean that
that that seems also like a better
recipe for more success I was feeling
it's like you take some really prominent
people in in different aspects of a
thing you know they're that all bring
something very strong you know to a
storytelling no scenario like if I'd
heard that like Prince's if I heard that
David Fincher was going to be directing
a movie written by Charlie Kaufman dabby
I don't know what that movie would look
like they would be super interesting
yeah like that sounds that sounds like a
pretty dope recipe yeah well maybe not
or like the Coen brothers are going to
be directing a Charlie Kaufman movie
that would be great that sounds dope
that I can yeah that that sounds like a
recipe for some for awesome miss ya yeah
I mean I'm interested like I'm a I'm big
don hertzfeldt fan but I understand what
makes don hertzfeldt work is that he's
the one man band but his projects are
things that can come from a one-man band
mmhmm yeah he does what he Donner's well
sets out to make a project it's the kind
of project that works being made by one
person well yeah I mean you know and I
think that's something that's important
to taking this talk to because it's like
it you know with movies and TV and stuff
you know when you have studio versus
director that almost seems like that
does seem a bit too narrow anyway
they're like it's giving one guy the
control versus giving like this so
select group of people whose job isn't
to do the creative stuff anyway the
country it's like it seems like a spread
would be a nicer you know no way to go
about it because then you can I want to
I want to see like an 18 make a bunch of
movies know of just really cool people
slap together like you know Clowe
doubtless I didn't see and it got really
high praise but also really you know a
lot of backlash and I got log of but it
was also
Cloud Atlas I'd be really interested to
sit down see because that's the
Wachowskis and Tom tickler yeah which is
you know which is a an interesting
recipe so I know County Fair did run
lola run okay yeah yeah see that's uh I
have I always heard the thing I heard
most about cloud atlas was that it was
like this has great elements and is it
was one of those like glorious failure
movies or it's like it doesn't achieve
what it set out to do what it sets out
to do but there is a lot of worth and
and you know investment here so I you
know you always know a couple people who
live like that but like that was the
sort of the most consistent thing I
heard about that movie was like yeah it
doesn't always come together but there
are some great things about it and we're
glad it's here yeah you know that's sort
of what everybody I sort of spoke to
about it said yeah I got standard
actually sit down see cloud atlas yeah
me too it always seems like an
interesting experiment name no um and
all that Asian make oh yeah yeah but all
that's yeah 1 TB is headed in an
interesting direction it seems like I
feel like there are bubbles forming and
I'm wondering which of them are going to
burst because you know we seem like now
more and more in America we're starting
to embrace the miniseries cuz you know
like in Britain it seems like they've
already yeah most of their programming
that becomes high-profile their
miniseries yeah or or you know only do a
few seasons and then that's it you know
and so I feel like we're finally
starting to embrace the miniseries which
is a good thing like like true detective
on paper was like oh cool you got a
couple of you know actors that were not
sort of a custom seeing in this kind of
a thing and a you know a missing you
know sort of a tot mystery with you know
jumps in time and whatever no again I I
still have to watch season one it's on
my list but um and then you know this
egg moving and the second scene is like
okay now we've got a whole different
sort of
cast of interesting people to be in a
show like this and you know another
story but it doesn't have to be bound to
the same you know Cinematic Universe
yeah exactly and it's like I like that
as a concept tonight I hope we can be
wise with it no it's like I hope Fargo
works out and then Fargo kind of falls
into under a different bubble is I guess
you it'd be more of like a Venn diagram
because now they're taking movies and
turning them in shows new and you know
we've proven from the onset of that that
that can work it's like Bates Motel I've
heard at least averages out to like it
is pretty good it seems like people like
it you know Hannibal people go nuts for
Hannibal Hannibal had a had a really
devoted fan base and I'd and I thought
it was a really cool show but whoa I
mean what was interesting about Hannibal
it's like seeing just how much i mean
just how much the show had to in a sense
compromise because it's on network TV
and granted they got away with a lot of
a lot of intelligence stuff that you
don't see on network TV and it got away
with you know a lot of graphic stuff
that you don't see on network TV with it
that's also it's like the first season
or so there's all this procedural stuff
and I just feel like this movie does not
need to be a cop forensic procedural
show like you you have something way
more intelligent than the forensic
procedural stuff going on it okay and
eventually the like that stuff kind of
fell by the wayside night I gotta catch
up on season 3 and see where it develops
but it's like it's been hard to want to
jump into it knowing that you know the
show has been cancelled knowing that the
demise is near yeah and the f so it's
finite yeah um but even so I mean and
and and it seems like they they sort of
sorted that out as this you know I got
imagine at least in the early stages
approaching like once you're turning a
movie or you know that case also books
into you know a TV series like it's got
to be kind of awkward especially when
network is involved yeah and I really
hope this is not a true rumor I
wonder because ever all this kind of
news is always subject to like it was
just a joke article or something but I
saw an article today um that I'm not
well if it's a joke i'm not aware but i
saw an article today that so they're
gonna make a friday the 13th TV series
on like fox or something would say again
no the CW yeah i read an article it is
the CW is gonna make a friday the 13th
series yeah seems like a terrible it's
like when they tried a different thing
cuz it was like a more semi original
idea but it's like when they try to do
the Playboy Club on on ABC it's like
yeah you can't like why would you make
Jason on on network tell me you can't do
the stuff that makes that thing what it
is like you know if you were gonna
screen one of these movies on a Saturday
night it would be super edited for TV
and now you're gonna do a network show
about Jason vorees it's like it seems so
soon here it seems like someone had the
idea of oh people like friday the 13th
let's make a property out of that so we
because it's got built in you know brand
recognition it's got built an audience
but then it's like what it's also
searching for how to continue it seems
like yeah what's also that next movie
has been has been an ordeal yeah they
went to space for God's sake they they
cut his face they do thats also like it
feels like whoever had that idea did not
take into account yeah really the reason
why people are into friday the 13th is
because they want to see interesting
they want to see kills they want and I
want to see Jason and graphic kills yeah
you know and that's like and sexy teens
yes laid by people in their late 20s and
every one of those movies pretty much
has like some sort of sex scene you know
with to get your TNA quotient it's like
this doesn't you know yeah FX are not
effects uh Stars has Evil Dead that
makes sense because stars doesn't have
those ratings right that the standards
restriction and it also there's what
people want out of Evil Dead are things
like you know the
the humor and continuing with the ash
character like I mean princess like army
a darkness in the evil dead trilogy is
actually kind of episodic yeah I mean
army they all are in a way BIA Evil Dead
2 almost functions in a way as a remake
or yeah do-over yeah so it's like you
know all the evil that feeble that
series has always been kind of episodic
so to turn it into it a TV show makes
sense because it's not like I mean uh
this I don't know if I've done I feel
like I've done this spiel before but for
instance like you know why the shrek
sequels were never that great pourquoi
because basically if you take a look at
the original shrek movie that movie is
very tightly structured very tightly
wound to be about you know and even in
the days of chris farley being the main
actor voicing shrek is now that that
early demo reel came out of Chris Farley
doing some voice acting for Shrek even
that far back the plan was the story is
about this ogre who is you know a
monster who you know felt hurt and we
had and became sequestered in his in his
isolation and thought that he wanted to
be I you know in isolation became his
misanthrope and what he has to do his
whole arc is yes to learn to be
vulnerable and let love in and trust
people and acceptance of like there's a
very specific arc to the character of
shrek in the movie Shrek but then once
you finish that arc it's like no the
character's development is done to do
another shrek movie is to just reach red
water yeah you know is just to tread
waters to retread old ground so it's
like you know the shrek sequels are like
now shrek is a combination of just a
wacky sitcom dad and you know a guy
going through oh I'm a no gramma freak
people don't yo say every f of every
it's like it's almost like every Trek
sequel had to redo oh well now there's
something new who doesn't accept track
for being an over so you just find
different
ways of men rehashing the same old
problem yeah which you know it doesn't
it doesn't work as and you have a
character that's kind of in stasis and
people get tired of it mmm where I say
Ashland evil dead ash in the evil that
has throughout the movies always been
getting sucked into a new Deadite
problem that he's had to like out wit
yeah you know he's I mean
personality-wise he's kind of always
been the same guy and that seems like a
joke that they're playing on like he's
still working at s Mart even though he's
in his fifties or sixties yeah exactly
it's been 30 years but he's still I
think they said he's even still a stock
boy is the same job like and and so the
riffing on the fact that no people what
makes ash kind of a fun character is not
necessarily as being a guy that's
developing its ash being a guy who stuck
yeah exactly and having to deal with
[ __ ] changing around him and they've
built you know they've built a loose
rules and you know the ability for
change into that serious cuz every movie
is a different kind of movie in a way
it's like the first one is a very low
fight kind of jarring zany but not
entirely intentionally zany you know
horror film and the second one it has a
lot of that like zany comedy but with
some you know still horror stuff that
ones like the truest blend of horror and
comedy and then the third one is mrs.
medieval supernatural action thing
action comedy no fantasy thing and that
also gets a knee and now in the new one
in the show at least they're they're
sort of it seems like they're almost
crashing some of the elements of the
remake into wherever army of darkness
left off so they're always sort of Evil
Dead has had many faces over time and
that helps this yeah you know where is
Jason Jason's Jason's Jason is Jason is
Jason forever like like jason has never
been a character Jason is just kind of
the thing yeah and even even when they
remade the movie in 2009 and they gave
him some different attributes like now
he can run just because we never did
that before like you know every actor
brings a posture and a person now but
and fly now he's in space yeah it's like
every every actor who dons the mask and
picks up the machete you know brings a
certain something but Jason is Jason
that kills the kills you know it's like
you don't have that potential for change
as much and ultimately like this doesn't
seem this is this is a very worrisome
idea to may not that I'm like losing
sleep Jason is fun to me but it's not my
like my favorite it's also i mean out of
all the I mean out of all the the the
big / or franchises Jason is the one
that's always been the same and jason
has always been the one that's almost in
a sense kind of been the most pure and
simple version of that cuz you know it's
like Michael Myers in the original
halloween it's you know it's got this
whole what made the original halloween
so interesting was that it was all about
kind of a more psychological way of
making you scared it played with shadows
it didn't show blood it didn't show
gourd it was you know it was about just
the suspense in the raw suspense of it
yeah I was closer to home cuz it's like
you don't see you know mangled bodies
and gore on a daily basis so it plays on
the things that you are familiar with
and the main character of the Halloween
franchise is Michael's sister so it's
like it's you know it does feel like
literally closer to home yeah exactly
you know um Freddy Krueger is has got
like a connection to the kids he haunts
the other there the kids of the parents
who vigilante killed him and then do
have the Surrealists think it's like you
know cuz Freddie comes to you in your
dreams you know crazy [ __ ] can go down
and beyond that it's like you know
Freddy is just kind of a an interesting
wisecrack II character it becomes a full
time he's always kind of but he doesn't
get like hey until later on yeah like it
starts happening in three but it still
works in three and then before it's like
this is a bit too much now yeah Kentucky
tone it down yeah calm down and I mean
that's the thing to you like comparing
those three is
like but then it's like you go you come
to friday the 13th it's just like no
just Jason he's mute and he shows up and
he kills you and screw samand and
teenagers with the titties yeah and
they're there are like a couple
connective threads between a few of the
movies you know you have like Tommy
Jarvis who is a character and at least
three of them except the nature of his
character completely changes for one of
them what kind of relevant but but very
much for one of them and they just sort
of ignore that and move on Michael's the
only one that seems to they always try
to sort of continuous story and those
are the ones that always remain serious
it's like Jason gets they become kind of
zany and fun after a while 86 is always
my favorite cuz it embraces the humor in
the in the most succinct way but yeah
she's like as a network television show
it seems like I don't know what you're
thinking like I see how scream I haven't
seen any of scream and I've heard most
the people i know have seen it because
nobody was like thrilled by the teasers
but most people i know have seen a few
episodes really know this is all right
you know that makes sense to me like
yeah scream on mtv sure like i get that
yeah and they can probably do that but
they can do cable stuff yeah exactly
like they might not be able to give you
everything but they can probably give
you enough whereas the CW nothing
against them but I don't I don't think
they can give us what know what Jason
movies like what people go to those
movies for ya like no one goes to a
friend of 13th movie to get involved in
engrossing the drama of the teenagers
yeah as the teenagers are supposed to be
dead within you know a few minutes yeah
it's like the best characters in in
those movies inevitably end up being the
ones who are written amusingly colorful
new just enough so that you that the
wallpaper is fun before the wallpaper is
dead you know it's like no one's hyper
interested in a serious romance story or
you know any number of things it's like
that again that's that's what I liked
about six was like every character who
shows up to add
the body count is a character hmm has
some interesting colorful dialogue but
will be dead soon and we will are clear
you know it's no more or less than it
has to be so I just can't see this and
hearing all the other things they've
gone through it's like it seemed like
they had some better ideas I just
thought it was something like I want to
see a teen slasher movie where two
teenagers go off into another room to
have sex and while they're in that room
at being sex the killer ends up like
taking out all of their friends who
aren't having sex and so the two kids
that did have sex are the ones who serve
the only way to stay safe is to be
[ __ ] yeah quick we have to [ __ ] why
he's in the building it comes to that
bombers I'd the killer like they're like
furiously like fear [ __ ] the the
serial killer comes to the room sees
them boning and then just gets really
awkward and comfortable kind of shifts
his weight and just backs out of the
room closes the door just really
uncomfortable with nudity yeah there's
an episode of Rick and Morty that has
their they're being experimented on by
these aliens and the only way for them
to get like privacy enough to plan some
kind of escape is to get naked I
remember this big David Cross is the
head of the aliens yeah exactly and
they're like these brilliant aliens
except like there's really uncomfortable
about nudity so they have to get naked
all the time I feel like that is justin
roiland trying to work in the premise of
his original doc and Marty that became
Rick and Morty cousin in the original
doc and Marty shorts that became Rick
and Morty it's just justin roiland doing
doc brown and Marty McFly from Back to
the Future where there are time problems
and they're all solved by a stock saying
you gotta lick my balls Martin am
already doing it and then that just
fixes the time problem and you can look
this up the real adventures of doc and
Marty it and that's that is basically
the pilots are Rick and Morty yeah it's
just Marty McFly licking Doc Brown's
balls and the [ __ ] up thing is it
works like every time problem instantly
fades away when Marty licks
oxballs yeah I was a great that was that
was a very interesting experience to be
like cuz at first is cookie you've kind
of feel gross and uncommon because it's
like oh he's looking this old mans nuts
weight is working with you working okay
[ __ ] no keep it up psexec would it
that's and you know it's that simple
twist of like oh what a lascivious pro
oh but it works yeah it's like well
that's a horrible because I mean that is
a joke that's like a lame-ass joke that
a Family Guy episode would pull words
like there's a problem in an old man
says oh just solve the problem you just
gotta lick my balls but then it doubles
back is like no it actually worked that
was the solution yeah that was the
actual solution of the problem the whole
time for no rhyme or reason it just
actually fixed everything I gotta start
seeing through breaking morning oh isn't
season two sorry they just greenlit
season three and I got to start season
two yeah quite like the wicked morning
yeah that's I got to get into watching
the morning hey folks we got to take a
dank aspirate a dank ass break but we'll
be back for more in part two and now a
word from our sponsor tonight's sponsor
is Terrance weakness yet again hey folks
do you like to be afraid of things of
course you do everyone loves to be in
terror and everybody also loves to
spooky yeah and you know where is the
best place to spooky ah totally spooky
days wherever it may be where yeah if
you can find Joey's few days it's the
best place to spooky in the northern
hemisphere easily yeah it's got it's in
fact in the northern image yeah it may
be it may be like Brigadoon where it
just kind of shows up somewhere randomly
every 100 years taraweeh spooning is a
lot like narnia is like you can only
find it when you're not looking for it
as kind of inconvenient for you to have
found it are those Narnia rules kind of
yeah well it doesn't normally only
appear in the cupboard if you are maybe
it's only when you need
yeah I don't know rules of [ __ ] but
anyway share with spooky day turn with
spooky days they have spiders and ghosts
and meets on hook um they got bathroom
now I do have a bathroom I think it's
just a porta potty yeah I mean there was
a photo of it there's a photograph in
the bathroom yeah so yeah so did some
love to our sponsor and we will see you
next time for part two well the daycares
grab bag of the dank ass grab bag old
medicine comedy hour later on